go is that loud enough
good welcome to all
attending I now have to read out the um
Evac emergency evacuation
announcement there are no planned fire
drills so if the alarm activates please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
by your nearest fire exit please use
either the fire exit through the main
doors of the hall or the fire exit in
the store room adjacent to the stage the
fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance of the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by Council of
Staff please note the meeting will be
live
streamed please switch off mobiles or
turn them to silent and a special
reminder for members and more
particularly especially for
myself members your voice will only be
captured on live stream when your
microphone is switched on so please
remember to switch your microphone on
when you're invited to speak and switch
it off again when you're not speaking so
thank you very
much now to the
agenda item one apologies for absence
I've been notified of apologies for
absence from councelor Michael
Hoy don't think there's any
others nonmembers
attending I'm just looking around make
sure there's nobody over there councelor
Simon won councelor I Foster councelor
Jim Gooding and I believe councelor
marot from from holbridge is visiting
welcome the next item is item three
minutes of the meeting held on the 18th
of
October do you all have them in front of
you are you happy that I signed those
minutes a true and Fair View of the
meeting that was held on the 18th of
October
yeah agreed thank
you item four to receive Declarations of
Interest are there any Declarations of
Interest
members there are
n questions on notice from counselors
I've been notified of
none item
six I understand that Council person
chair of the on committee is not able to
attend this
evening so I will run this item in AIT
another way it item six is the one te
transformation program strategic
partnership with Brentwood Bar Council
quarter 2
update uh Greg Campell the author of the
update the original update that went to
the overview and scrutiny committee is
here
I'm going to ask him please to run
through the report very
briefly and also I understand you're
going to cover um the presentation of
the report of
on to the same item is that
correct sorry sh which which item to it
six I'm yeah I'm talking to the one team
this evening the
report that I did previously to on yes
okay and you and you'll be also speaking
to the report of on in response oh yes
thank you thank you Mr Mr
Campbell okay over to you
sir thank you chair and sorry for that
confusion I justly realized what you're
asking me apologies evening members so
before you tonight is the uh one team
report that went to ons it is the cover
it covers Quarter Two which is May to
July so sometime back back now things
have moved on but talking to the report
before us and I'll probably come on to
the item that was raised at on that is
also mentioned in the report before you
um I'll come on to that at the end when
we talk about risk because that was what
it related to um things have been going
well within terms of one team what we've
been developing what we've been pushing
forward service reviews have continued
to move it at the right pace and coming
through to the program board to be
considered what I can say is
Communications and HR are now now
complete they're fully embedded and all
positions that are to be to be filled
have been filled what I can also say is
emergency planning business continuity
risk management uh customer services
and procurement sorry remember that one
are all going through their consultation
process at the moment so over the next
couple of months that process should be
complete and all teams will be therefore
moved into the one team um reviews
continue support for staff is still
being maintained uh by regular meetings
with them by myself going around to see
the staff once a month making sure that
they've got any questions providing
support through HR through the um care
schemes that we've got going on as well
there's also support that come through
from the one team on projects and
programs which now provides um the
ability for projects to be seen by both
organizations uh so they they can be
managed in a proactive way um coming on
to the item that's been raised here
around risk management and if I just
refer to the report that further risk be
added to the risk register relating to
staff accommodation and Welfare that
could impact upon staff from
morale um we have since this point had a
risk management Workshop which
specifically looked at the risks around
one team this was included in that it
was a joint Workshop across both
authorities and that will now reflect in
the risk register that you see before
you so next time the risk that come out
of that the risk that we've been looking
at and we had the workshop on will be
reflected in the new document that comes
forward to you uh it was a good Workshop
we went through a number of risks we
identified any new potential risks what
the mitigations could be and we're
working through them
now that it any any further questions
from anyone thank you Greg
um Greg Campbell's inviting any
questions members uh in relation to the
original
report
um and uh we will discuss the
recommendation separately so do you have
any questions to ask of Mr Campbell in
the original report the Q2
update councelor Stanley thank you thank
you chairman um we did uh mention at the
work workshop
uh earlier um several things that came
to light with uh our staff um and
hopefully we will get that report of
what was mentioned uh as to the Staffing
levels and also the what is the criteria
that is making our
staff uh having time out um as it's
quite high at the
moment um we saw the graph being quite
High 600 or 700 hours I believe it
something like that um so there was was
there something that was going to come
to us can I um can I interrupt
you item seven covers all of the issues
you you have raised so could we wait
till item
seven that's right no problem
any other questions members
please
okay I just want to draw your particular
attention to the
recommendation uh it's on page
6.1.1 uh it is proposed that the
executive
resolves that further risk be added to
the risk register relating to staff
accommodation and Welfare that could
Impact Staff morale
I would like to ask a question myself
before we
discuss that recommendation I'd like to
ask the question of the CEO Jonathan
Stevenson who's uh who's here
tonight Jonathan this is my question as
program sponsor for one team do you
think there is a current risk around
staff
morale particularly in relation to staff
accommodation and would you be
supportive of adding such a risk to the
risk
register thank
you thank you chair and thank you for
the question um with regard um that's
probably a two-part question actually
with regards to morale generally um when
you're going through any change program
there is some drops in morale especially
when different people are affected so we
monitor that in the report later we'll
talk about how we monitor more generally
around that um so morale when you going
through change and looking at
restructuring looking at different
service design that that is the case
with regard to accommodation we all know
as an organization that we've been on a
journey looking at um our staff
accommodation um from closing the Civic
Suite originally um moving most of our
um staff to um South Street and then
looking at other options moving moving
forward um we've also had a pandemic in
between that as well uh a number of
those things that's course the the work
space itself at South Street as I've put
in the report um later in the um the
next item at 6.3 the the venue itself
doesn't lend itself to collaborative
ways of working which is the way most
people now work when they come in the in
their office space not many people come
into the office space to work in a
single office on their own if they're
going to do that they do that at home so
to answer your question um it's not just
from the one team but with regards to
the accommodation there is obviously a
pressure moving forward that we need to
find a solution to accommodation to um
because it is a is a common question
asked at all our staff briefings that
sort of what next but I know we are now
working on Solutions or we're working on
solutions to to deal with that on an
interim and longer term basis as well
hopefully that asks your
question yes thank you Jonathan are
there any other questions from other
members on the
recommendation I would like to propose a
replacement recommendation having heard
what Mr Stevenson has had to say and I'd
like to add one as
well I'll I'll read them out and then
you have the opportunity obviously to
discuss
them the first one which I'll call
R1 is that the executive notes the
progress of the one team transformation
program and I'm making that because we
have reviewed the original report at r
two that the executive asks
the one team program board to include a
risk relating to staff accommodation and
Welfare that could impact on staff
Morale on the risk register and that
would be a replacement of the published
recommendation from
on I have a second do so councelor
second that councelor James Newport is
seconding it thank you
floor's
open councilor
Stanley uh just one thing that comes to
mind is do we have a time limit on the
risk um in other words do we have a
three month or a six month uh to
quantify what
we're doing to a staff the staff
accommodation and such like put I'll be
going to put a a an intering time limit
to give us up toate information well
thanks for your question would either Mr
Campbell or Mr Stevenson like to answer
that I thank you chair thank you m um
when the risks are put onto the risk
register there will be mitigations
against those risks uh and that provides
a regular report back whether it be
through the one team although this is
more of a corporate risk I would have
thought and it sit on that Reg and there
it would be a mechanism for reporting
those back but there should be mechanis
Ms within there which are the
mitigations that shows how we're going
to progress those risks to reduce them
over time the one you're talking about
is obviously not something that need can
be finished or sorted quite quickly but
there should be some updates in there
about the work that we're doing to we
find new accommodation how we can
relieve the stress that's there or the
pressure that may be there at the moment
so that should be included in the risk
mitigations is there anything further
you want me to
add
thank you any other questions
members okay in which case I shall
put the seconded
proposals before you one by one and
we'll take a vote upon them R1 that the
executive notes the progress of the one
team transformation prog
program those in favor of the
proposal unanimous with me thank
you
R2 that the executive asks the one team
program board to include a risk relating
to the staff accommodation and Welfare
that could impact on staff Morale on the
program risk
register those in favor please please
show
hands un it is now
unanimous I'd just like to
check was a good idea members remember
to turn on the
mic members we now move to item seven
the workforce overview 22 23
2324 and since the all member briefing
which was available on Tuesday night um
I understand that 221
222 um figures have been added to an
amended report and circulated to all
members and posted on SE Miss for the
public to
see this report comes from the chief
executive
and head of paid
service Mr Jonathan Stevenson so I'll
ask him to present and speak to the
report thank
you thank you chair um members uh as the
chair said in front of you got report um
item seven the workforce overview um
2022 23 23 and 24 and the amendment 2021
and 22 um just to assist members um
following the meeting on Monday which
the all all members briefing um there
was the Amendments the report suggest
one members to add the 2021 22 figures
which we've been able to to get but to
help members um these been added in
point
1.3 2.1 to 2.2 3.3 and 3.6 of the report
um just just to help with that they are
the only additions to the report that's
been already on the on the website
previously um it's unusual to add things
and make an amendment but as it was
suggested by members a number of members
on the call it was it was was good to
add those figures into you've got all
the figures in front of you in the
meeting this is the first time that I'm
aware that a report of this kind has has
come to Executive for the council the
intention was to to bring a report
annually um on figures for for Rochford
and with the one team moving forward
possibly figures taking into account
brenwood as well but at this moment in
time we're looking at a Rochford only
report looking back over the last two
years and the current year we're in
obviously just for for members 2021 22
and 2020 21 were were different years
with in our in our living times so there
is some figures in there but obviously
take into account we're in we're during
lockdowns and covid for some of that as
well so just better I'm sure people know
that but I just want to highlight that
as the case more than happy to take any
questions on the report um if anybody's
got any questions thank you
chair
members we have council Mrs Wilson okay
uh thank you chair my question is uh to
uh our CEO Mr Stevenson via yourself if
that's okay um I'm referring if you uh
look at page 7.3 par
2.18 I'm I'm aware that um I'm talking
about the turnover figure that um the
turnover figure for this year is um
apparently significantly lower than uh
the previous year but if as your figures
uh suggest it will be a 9% uh turnover
rate that is still an awful lot in an
organization um when staff leave um I
know that you've confirmed the exit form
to being done um are there any Trends
what are these exit forms telling us
please thank you councelor Wilson um Mrs
Wilson with regard to do reference 7.3
did you say was that page oh sorry page
page 7.3 uh par two 2.18 yeah okay no
problem um I should have said earlier as
well um Nicola man is here tonight as
well inter director of P governance to
help me with some of the inal so with
regard to the turnover rates obviously
with a small organization the turnover
percentages can be quite high so for
this organization of Circ 150 people 15
people is 10% so obviously it's still
still the context because obviously
small organizations do the same um
previous years the turnover rate as you
see and it was brought up at the um the
all member briefing is um the last two
years in particularly last year we had a
high level of retirements for an
organization of 150 we had six
retirements in that period of time um
also had a number of um
resignations some a lot of those were
down to promotion or moving on to other
organizations with regards to your
question around um exit interviews where
we can we have an exit interview with
all staff is is a voluntary we encourage
them um but and and most of the time
people undertake those um with their
line manager or someone independent if
that's if that's the case they've got an
opportunity to do that as well um with
regard to the technical side of that I'm
happy for Nicola to pick up any
questions around that if I've missed
anything thank you I think the question
was was there any Trends so what I was
have the exit questionnaires that we
have received there is nothing to
suggest there's a trend people are just
choosing to make different choices and
and leave there's nothing there that
would show us a trend at this moment
to come back uh yes please it's it's
more of a comment and a concern really I
don't think for for response but um
normally in small
organizations um any um turnover rate
more than six or seven percent is a
concern because smaller organizations
tend to become families so the turnover
rate does tend to be historically lower
um and yeah I'm just concerned I know
there's a lot of change going on but
nevertheless the numbers are still quite
High that's just all I wish to say thank
you chair um thank you councel Mr Wilson
again I know looking for a response but
just obviously the direction of travel
we're looking it's looking to come down
that's what we're looking to do you're
right turnover rates are a key for folks
on organization from the data and
information we've got we don't see there
Trends and reason obviously just people
making change of life decisions um we're
monitoring that now we'll monitor it
moving forward and we report back we're
looking to do this on an annual basis a
minimum or by exception if there is a
reason to to bring back any concerns to
the um to
Executive okay councilor Stanley did you
indicate thank you chairman um can I
bring your attention to
7.2
21 um and 23 22 and
23 um it says here that we got 43
vacancies become vacant yet we
recruited uh 25 25
positions and there was still 10
vacancies where recruitment to follow
multiple recruitment campaign so I don't
know if those positions
were taken those 10 vacancies were taken
up which leaves us with
35 out of the
43 um which there's eight more positions
to be accounted for I don't know if
they've been accounted for or not um and
also we
had
um 28 officers left the organization
apart from the
retirements and
well we got resignations of
18 what was the what was the thought
behind that of those people that left
was it be what for what it doesn't say
show for what reason that that was gone
apart from obviously they want to maybe
uh step up the ladder or that sort of
thing and I just wonder where we why you
know as we losing good
officers
um it it just
seems it just seems to me that we need
to look into that a little bit further
and the fact that we've got 22 positions
which have been recruited
externally why have we done 22 positions
externally why why haven't we got them
on our
staff um that's my first question my
second question is with the number of
hours lost of
730 days
lost um can you
say where those 730 days have been lost
is it to um people that are working
outside in weather conditions or is it
those majority of days lost for those
working in offices of
RDC I think those are the two questions
thank you Nicola is is that for you to
respond or um would Jonathan like to do
so okay thank you councelor Stanley um
thank you chair um with regard to just
just to me clarify this on 2.7 um there
was 45 vac became vacant newly created
and advertised 25 positions were
recruited to directly and 10 vacancies
recruited to following multiple
recruitment campaign so that my
understanding that's 35 so eight posts
weren't recruited to either single
advertisement or multiple advertisements
so there was a deficit of filling post
of of eight posts um 22 posts were
recruited in externally so of the 35 13
of those were were were internally and
it doesn't say that directly in the
report but that was that was what what's
happened so that was the eight post so
that hopefully clarifies the point
obviously there is there was eight posts
that weren't recruited to in that period
of time the the the question was we've
recruited 22 positions are they external
operators to the council or are
they employed by the council at the
council offices the themselves it
they're externally I thought that that
was an
external uh okay person that you've got
recruited rather than into the council
no just for clarification so that's 22
people came from outside of the council
to work for the council in that period
of time and 13 people were recruited
internally by for promotion or moving
posts within the organization so that
made the 35 with eight posts left vacant
um to does that help with that one that
question partially I just wanted to know
if those people that recruited
externally are they now on our staff in
the council or are they external people
like we've got with with enforcement and
and such like but that's
all sorry we can go on to the other
question if we can
700 thank you chair and thank you
councelor Stanley um so yeah just to
clarify they were external now they are
internally on our books on our books as
employees of the council so just to
clarify that your other question
actually before I go to the we talked
about the resignations retirements uh
this as well I think you just
highlighted the number I think um
previously I gave a bit of context
around that about people career
progression people have moved on to
different jobs um Co provide
opportunities some that actually people
working close to home or working from
home and obviously not all of our roles
allow people to work from home all the
time and actually our principles we ask
people to come into place two or three
days a week as well so some people made
some life choic around that that that
that period of time so there was an
increase also to remind Stu uh members
is during that period of time the
organizations did come together as the
one team and obviously there was a
reduction in that of the senior level of
staff so we saw a high proportion of
senior staff coming together and make
decisions to leave the organization
because we went from Two Chief execs to
one four directors to to two and 12 um
corporate directors to nine so there was
obviously a some rationale around that
as well with regard to your um sickness
I'll pass over to Nicola to perhaps
comment on that and happy to come back
in if needed
so hi thank you just to clarify was it
um in relation to
3.6 um 2022 2023 long-term absences we
was 730 is that the one you're referring
to okay so um when we looked at the
figures we didn't distinguish kind of
the type of role that a person was doing
we distinguish between longterm and
shortterm um definition of longterm
being 20 days or more um and then what
we did is we looked at those members of
who were off for 20 days or more and the
top reasons for absence which in this
case was was sort of cancer related
absences or cardiac absences so they
were the main reasons so we didn't break
it down into whether they might be in
saf Street or whether they might be
maybe in the Parks or something like
that we didn't we didn't do
that thank you Nicola thank you
Jonathan you you want to come back
please okay thank you thank you chair um
I I understand what you're saying but um
when you say cardiac and uh other uh
causes are we saying that majority of
that
730 was that result of that or what are
we saying with that 730 because my view
is that if that is a known cause that
there is um tension in the office that's
causing these heart conditions cardiac
rests and that sort of thing surely we
should be doing something in relation to
what is the cause and how we would how
we would mitigate that with those people
if it's outside work where we're asking
for too much on inclement days uh
working throughout the rain and I do
know they
do is that a a cause as well where we
should look at what's going on and try
try to mitigate those
positions personally personally
councelor stany I think we're going too
far expecting too much but I'll allow
Nicola to
reply yeah thank you chair and thank you
C just to reassure members obviously
there's some figures in this in the
paper that talks about high level
numbers and we do look at those types of
things we're talking about with regard
to long-term sickness it's mainly
underlining health issues things that
are not directly impacted from the work
we obviously investigate things like
that but there is no direct link with
short-term sickness there is sometimes
we look at I know flu things like that
have people CAU that from working in
different conditions have so things that
respiratory problems or or muscle
problems things like that things that
may be linked to manual working that
would be something we look at the the
issues unfortunately as an organization
we had a number of people on long-term
sickness because of underlining health
issues that they're not directly linked
to the to the work into the workforce so
but I understand that concern but with
regard to shortterm in particular when
things do come up like muscle injuries
things like that and if they're mainly
Frontline staff we would look into that
to consider is that the impact of the
job they're doing um so hope that
helps any other members
please counc Mrs
Wilson thank you chair for allowing me
to come back I should have asked this
them all at once however I didn't um
we've covered sickness I thank you
Council for that that's um asked my
question sort of um my my next question
is um regarding your golden ticket
scheme which I have to say um in my view
has to be highly commended because it's
all good staff motivation and good for
staff morale could you let me know
please because it's not in the report in
this I've missed it what percentage of
staff at Rochford would normally receive
a Golden Ticket
award dur during the year
[Music]
20 thank you chair yeah um thank you
chair and thank you counc M Wilson I
haven't got that figures in front of me
obviously we' with rewarded recognition
is for people who have gone above and
beyond in any year what we try not to do
is Target an amount because if there's
more people going above and beyond one
year it' be wrong to say sorry we've
only got to 10 golden tickets but there
is a budget within the within the
council we have to try and work to but
again there is some tolerance with that
and I would speak to Carri if people
have gone above and beyond one year we
wouldn't restrict that we wouldn't
reward people um I obviously people go
above and beyond every day but these are
significant people going above and
beyond so if that's a case so I can get
a number to of how many we' had in
previous years um during covid it's
difficult because obviously lots of
people went by Beyond so there wasn't as
many rewarded for that period of time
because everybody was so but when there
significant things that happened within
the council either individuals or teams
and I think on the on the meeting this
week we talked about if a team's awarded
they don't share the golden ticket
there's a there's a there's a um um a
gift for each member of the team not not
they don't have to share their prize
so thank you Mr
Stevenson okay I'm now looking around to
see if there are any further questions
on the workforce review from
Members not um
the report is for
noting and I'll ask the committee to do
so in a moment but I want to thank uh Mr
Stevenson
and Nicola man for bringing this report
forward earlier than
expected um as it has been well received
by members not just of the executive but
members of the council as a whole and I
do do hope that um this will then become
a a regular annual report for for
consideration Jonathan I understand you
wish to say something else
course thank you chair for let me come
in I just would like to if this aocc to
put on record because um Zoe SE isn't
here this evening um because she's on a
development program herself which is
great but she done an awful lot of work
put the report together you I know um
you you might not be aware of that
behind the scenes she's covering from
she's doing our inter HR manager I think
be nice to B record her the thanks for
her as
well thank you Jonathan um members do we
agree to note the report agreed agreed
thank
you in which case we now move to item
eight item eight quarter 2 budget
monitoring to consider the report of the
executive lead member for resources
climate change in economy setting out
the forecast revenue and capital budget
positions as at the end of quarter 2
2324 well the executive lead member is
is unfortunately unable to attend so if
I may I'd like to invite the um the
report author carck Cox finance manager
um to lead us through thank you thank
you chair um this report sets out the
forecasts for revenue and capital spend
as at the end of sep member the table on
page 8.2 shows a forecast under spend of
281,000 and it's broken down into the
surfice areas by salary and the
non-salary variances the variances are
then explained in more detail on page
8.4 onwards the main reasons for the
variance is we've received £430,000
additional investment income due to
higher interest rates and this has been
offset by pressures on the mhoo
expenditure and housing benefit
expenditure the capital program can be
found found in appendix 3 on page 8.21
that's showing a expected 2.1 million
pound slippage which is mainly due to
the 1.78 million pounds that was
allocated for the ADP which is now
subject to review I'm happy to take any
questions thank
you members uh have you any questions
for Gary Cox on the quarter two outturn
please I think the report has been
around several times in various various
places informally do you have any any
further
questions apparently not in which case
again a report which uh gratefully
received from C and
Jim um they are welcomed it is a useful
and appropriate
update uh the committee welcomes it
thank you so members do we note the
report
noted thank
you I now move to item nine item nine is
the installation of skate
parks um to consider the report of the
executive lead member for leisure
tourism and well-being I think you must
have the longest
title um recommending the council
continues to deliver on its place Bas
Improvement program that's councelor
Julie Gooding and we also have um Marcus
hotton director of environment here as
well I'm not sure who's going to start
but you're more than welcome to
choose Thank You chair I'll uh I'll just
start off with uh obviously we've all
seen the report um skateboarding BMX and
scooters are considered a relatively
inexpensive activity once the equipment
has been provided did it's a safer place
for people to enjoy leisure activities
than Street skateboarding and and skate
parks provide recreational activities
for broad spectrum of age and gender to
enjoy
socializing uh currently both hullbridge
and rley skate park have reached their
end of life and no longer fit for
purpose uh in the report it is noted
that Clemens Hall requires further
consideration in respect of sighting and
noise levels due to the proximity to the
local residents and
properties if anyone has any questions
I'm happy to answer before questions I'd
invite Mr hotton to say a few words if
that's
appropriate thank you chair um if I can
bring your attention to um 2.9 in the
report this just more for clarity than
anything else I mean it uh it mentions
the details of skate park design and
location and set out in appendix 3 this
is more just for clarity for for those
that canot access appendix 3 because
it's it's exempt um so the the location
in itself isn't isn't uh sensitive at
all it's just it happens to be part of
the the design bid that was sub
submitted which is commercially
sensitive so it's unfortunate it's put
in there it's an oversight on my behalf
which I apologize for so to clear that
the actual sighting of it is at R Ledger
sentor it's in the report but it does
mention elsewhere um Swain Park
originally in the consultation but it
was um decided it was going to be at the
r Leisure Center um so it's not um
citing as it is now which is tucked down
right next to to The Ledger Center but
it's brought up onto the same level as
the playing field so there's better
sight lines and S natural surveillance
of that skate park thank
you thank you Mr hton thank you very
much counselor Mrs Gooding members
any
questions right I'm going to take
counselor M Newport first thank
you thank you chair I'd like to ask what
um what is the environmental impact as a
whole on the new installation of the
skate
parks so the actual footprint itself is
not that large so I think you're finding
an ecological impact on on what is uh um
a playing field Short Grass the impact
is is what you deem Min minimal um uh in
terms of the actual um if you like uh
design and build of the skate park I
haven't got a an answer to hand in terms
of of its footprint but but in um that
would not be used usually as a scope of
the um footprint of the organization
it's it's a one-off development so once
it's built it still has minimal impacts
at that St
thank
you had answer your question thank you
um councelor
Stanley please thank you chair um
could the officer advis us as to when
the skate parts will start to be
installed and also the maintenance of
the cost of what would he consider to be
the cost of Maintenance to these skate
parks please thank
you I'm I'm relu to an exact time scale
at this stage until we've awarded the
contract uh and then we'll be able to at
least discuss with the um the contractor
those that sort of um time scale we can
obviously bring that back if there
something you wish to know Council
Stanley um but I would anticipate that
from um design potentially planning
application uh and an approval and then
development you may be looking at still
12 months before they're completed uh in
terms of Maintenance costs uh I don't
have a figure to hand what I do know is
that they will um be less than the cost
of the the existing skate parks to to
maintain because I think as you're aware
um the nature of the existing skate pars
are such that the maintenance C quite
they're taking a heavy burden on on the
budgets and although we allow for that
um a concrete design would be of a lower
maintenance cost what we're um paying
out for the moment
thank you Mr hton um I have councilor
Williams thenk councilor EES councilor
Williams thank you yeah thank you
chairman um Mark I was just wondering
when these were being designed were pump
tracks considered at the same
time they were discussed I think um
realistically so the design of these
tries to incorporate um BMX bikes where
possible I think pump tracks are of a
different scale you'd have to have a
separate design on top of of these I
think to do so so I think that's
something um that uh um certainly lead
member expressed a desire to me to
pursue and we are going to do so but I
think it the budget was originally
allocated for replacing existing skate
pars which would end of their
lives yeah thank you excellent thank
you is that
complete okay c e thank you chair um I
note in the report we're looking at
these being replaced because previous
ones have come to end of life um with
the new parks that are looking to come
in do we have an expectation of how long
these things will be considered usable
which will give us an idea an
inclination as to how much value we're
going to be getting out this spin please
thank
you I mean so um there have been views
of up to 4 40 years but the warranty is
20 years so I I would go with the 20
years so so I think you get at least 20
years minimum use out of each of these
Parks I'd like to think he a bit bit
longer than that but yes thank
you it's always an aspiration councilor
Rees any further questions
members no further questions there are
two recommendations I always like to
take them
separately so
R1 is to award ra Leisure Center skate
park contract to Betton park at a cost
of
138,000
okay those in favor of the
recommendation
please no it's okay um just take take a
step back I've made an
error thank you very much Sonia for
pointing out I need a proposer for the
recommendation councelor Mrs Gooding and
and a seconder councelor Stanley so
having completed the right and proper
process for which I apologize for
missing can we now please indicate in
favor of the
recommendation
yes I'm allowed that is
unanimous the second
recommendation second it proposed by
councelor Mrs Gooding seconded by
councelor Mrs
Wilson R2 to award pool's Lane halbridge
skate park contract to Betton park at a
cost of
$3,576
54 with those in favor of the
recommendation please show
hands again that is unanimous thank you
members I'll just turn over the page in
case they' fooled
me which they haven't
and I'd like to thank everyone for
attending thank you for the officers for
for for
attending the visitors for
attending and I close the meeting at um
8:16 thank
[Music]
you